[Music]
let's go to sydney in dayton ohio what's
up sydney
good morning
sorry i
they told me to do a countdown off air
and
i was counting in spanish and then they
said that i shouldn't turn the mic on so
you got to hear me counting in spanish
that's what that was all about we're
helping out something new we're helping
out the youtube kids and i do like
spanish it's my favorite language
alright so what's up
so
i live with a guitar shredding peter pan
is his name james childs by any chance
no it's not all right just wondering
a guitar shredding peter band that's
that's my favorite all right tell me
about this
he
lives breathes sleeps eats guitar that
is all he he's incredible i'd say he is
incredible but that is all he is
interested in doing and that's all he
does
does he earn a living playing guitar
not really
no i am i have a very i i take care of
everything
well not everything is into donald's he
takes care of
he
he does make money he could he could be
professional
he just doesn't have the motivation i
take care of the house i own the house i
clean the house i repair the house i do
the car repairs
so how can i help
is there a way i can motivate him
what are you getting out of this
oh i have a blast with him he's sweet
he's affectionate
what else i've always taken care of
myself always okay i have always been
independent i have kept myself separate
financially
from everybody i've been with
you have a lot of fun how old are
you old enough to know better
you're getting something out of this
what is it
companionship
great attention why is this where you
have landed
as your as your benchmark for
companionship
well it's not about him this is a story
about you
yeah
i lost someone after 13 years okay
pastor passed away
yeah okay from addiction yep
and during that addiction i was totally
neglected for about eight years yep
and then after he passed
i met this one and he just
hugs me and holds my hand and pays
attention and loves me and shows it
and that for your body
for your spirit that was worth the trade
for a season
yeah
living living eight years with an addict
you're is
it's like somebody
putting a plastic bag over your head you
can't breathe and then you're allowed
one one gulp of air you know every every
two minutes right you can't breathe for
eight years
and all of a sudden somebody takes that
bag off your head and somebody comes up
and just pumps oxygen into you for a
season right
and it feels so good
it sounds like you got a kid
you got a pet exactly
because you're a mom right now you're
not somebody's girlfriend
that is how i feel
that's what you are
yeah your feelings are accurate
often our feelings lie to us your
feelings are not lying
so you've got a child that you take care
of
and that offers you
sex intimacy and
human connection
what else
humor
yes i mean you can watch anchorman
reruns to get humor like what are they
what are they offering you
like you're getting something out of
this is it safety is it security is it
you can't fathom starting over yet again
like what what is it
no that doesn't scare me
yes it does
not really not starting over i love
change okay so break up with him today
well i don't want to hurt him
because he's not because he's your kid
yeah
yeah i was being facetious about
breaking up with him
that your response
confirms what you already know
your instant response was not but i love
him and i want to spend the rest of my
life with him it was now i'm trying to
protect him
and no relationship can be built on
protectionism like that
protection is a part of a relationship
but it comes from a deep-seated sense of
love and
interconnectedness
how long have you all been together
um
four years whoo
you can tell me you're not afraid of
change
your body knows this story
the story of
lost the story of being single the story
of waking up and there's nobody next to
you your body knows that story
you can tell me like nah it's cool man
it's not that's gonna be hard
be real real hard
is that true
that is true yeah
i hate to admit that but that's true
one of the one of i mean there's so many
one of the great evils of living and
loving somebody who is
an addict
is you lose sense of yourself you feel
crazy every day
right
you feel you feel untethered you feel
disoriented just making your way through
the world because the person you love is
also the person that hurts you the most
and your body and your brain have to
toggle back and forth between
i'm in love and i care and i'm trying to
keep well
and i'm being hurt all the time either
through neglect or positive right all
the time
and
you feel bananas
and it can
lead to one of two things hyper
codependence or
an addiction to absolute stoic control
you hit it no relationship can survive
either of those extremes
i fall in my life a little bit more on
the let's figure it out live whew
and my wife falls more on the
list-making side
like we have to have somebody that pays
the bills in this house john
and so there's there's there's degrees
here
but my guess is just listening to you if
you just you put your feet in concrete
on the control side i will control every
variable from this point forward to the
point that i'm gonna date
and be intimate with a child so i can be
that in control because part of you is
so terrified to risk love again
true
connected
partnership love
because with that risk comes great hurt
and you felt it
oh yeah
and the hard scary sucky part of love is
the only way it works is if you risk if
you go all in
otherwise you end up
sleeping with a
guitar shredding peter pan
right
and peter pan was a child
so you you knew calling this you knew
calling me
that you've got some hard decisions to
make what are you going to do
i feel like i'm leading you and i don't
want to be leading you
right what are you going to do
i really
it's eventually things are going to have
to change
so what i'm telling you is they're not
going to
i mean with myself ah there you go have
you sat down and said dude you got to
get a job
oh yeah
yeah not well
[Music]
you're so smart what do you do for a
living
well i ran a company for a few years and
i
am a recruiter
okay
and do you do well recruiting
oh yeah
yeah
i'm able to take care of myself
and him but um
okay but you're wearing that as a badge
of honor
you have not dealt with being married
and in love with an addict have you
no
you have that that hurts way too much to
think about you have to deal with that
the idea that
your status your level of success
is i can take care of myself
that's the most fundamental like that is
benchmark one to just being an adult
that's nothing to be said for i
experience joy
i actually have true laughter i've got
true relationships where i risk where i
love or i give and i take and i disagree
and i fight and i come back and i love
harder the next time like
you're still so wrapped
into your original pain
that j like i take care of myself yeah i
hope you do you're an adult yeah and
you're really freaking smart
and one of my closest people to me in
the world is a world-class recruiter and
you got to be real savvy and real smart
and very quick
and stay up late and get up early and
all those twists and turns of that job
and i know you can do that but you got a
blind spot here you haven't dealt with
the original pain why are you scared to
go in you say it's gonna hurt so bad why
i don't know i just
i've never felt anything like that i've
had loss
but
i tried so hard to
keep him alive and do everything i could
hey
yeah his death is not on you
it feels like it you got to put that
story down sister
he didn't die because of you
it took me a long time to figure out i
couldn't do anything though in it while
i was in the throes of it
i tried everything of course you did
because i could think of because you
loved
but you still wake up every morning with
the feeling
with a brick in your backpack that you
killed your husband and that's not true
it's not true
that story doesn't hold water
it's a myth
and that brick is keeping you from
relationships that you deserve
from
joy and laughter that you deserve from
sleep
man you talk about people who can't
sleep be married to an addict
right oh yeah the fear all night long
all night long
yeah you still don't sleep do you
nope i wake up every night a few times a
night
can i tell you you deserve to lay down
go to sleep and sleep all night
you deserve somebody who will love you
and participate in
bills
participate in
what you want to do joy all that stuff
you gotta set that brick down i want you
to say out loud
what was his name
the one that passed yep
chris
i want you to say out loud
i am not responsible for chris's death
i am not responsible for chris's death
you just said that in a very clinical
way i want you to drop your shoulders
all the way down you had to you had to
say it to get through it and i get it i
want you to drop drop your shoulders all
the way down
drop them they're clenched up around
your ears right now i can feel it
drop them down
and say it
i'm not responsible for chris's death
i am not responsible for chris's death
and today before the day is over
you have one homework assignment
that's to call somebody and say
it's time for me to start healing
and my promise to you is this when you
start healing from that trauma that
you've experienced and you've been
through a lot
the death is big
the death is the big acute trauma
but you experienced so much you know
this cognitively
your body's holding so much
pain
still
still vigilant still trying to keep
things going
so much so that it will take
love from a child just to keep some
oxygen pumped into your heart until you
can keep going
i want you to call a counselor and say
today's the day
make that first call i gotta start
healing
will you do that for you
i absolutely will you promise
i promise you're the bravest person i
will talk to this week
did you know what you're gonna have to
walk the the harrowing hallway you're
gonna have to walk down to heal this
right
yeah a lot of tears i've been holding
back yeah man
think how exhausted your body is from
not wanting to feel for so long
from carrying that guilt and that weight
think about it as a backpack full of
bricks think how tired your body is
when you finally set that stuff down and
let that stuff go and let that stuff out
your body
you're gonna sleep oh my gosh sister
and then
you'll look over and go what are you
doing in here man
peter
work or go
i'm freaking sydney from dayton
i'm not a mom
i'm a woman who's gonna have
a relationship that is
egalitarian we're gonna love each other
we're gonna support each other and we're
gonna run for the hills together
i'm not gonna be anybody's mommy unless
i have my own children
that fair
that is fair
you're the bravest person i'm gonna talk
to you
now here's the thing you make that call
and get an appointment on the calendar
and you your your homework assignment is
to
email me back and let me know i did it
okay cool
i will do that if you don't i'm gonna
publicly shame you i'm just kidding i'm
not gonna do that
okay
i promise i promise
you're worth
more than all of this
you're worth more than all this
you get a heart sometimes i know huh
sometimes i know that
i know because you're smart
and you're
i guarantee you're a fun person you're
an exhausted person
anxious exhausted person
and you just deserve more than that
simply because you're my sister because
you live in my country you're my friend
you're breathing you're a person on
planet earth anything you want to throw
in there
it's time to heal
it's time to heal and then get on to the
next chapter that is whatever you want
to make it
first step first step down the down the
track starts today so proud of you
sydney